you definitely don't get the same level
of mentorship accountability and being
developed the same way as you do just
sitting behind it because obviously we
know from going in meetings being in
meetings and coming out and then like oh
what you think about this or oh don't
forget about this or just those small
touch points those don't happen because
on Zoom it's like click you're done and
then you're off and then you're like all
right what's next now so I definitely
think that there's a big part of that
where people would enjoy the freedom of
it but don't understand potentially the
long-term kind of setbacks it can create
because a lot of those interpersonal
interactions are what really allows you
to grow and develop over time